- Hi, I'm Grace.
- I'm Mamrie.
And together, we have a show
called "This Might Get" on YouTube.
And today, we're doing this.
- We're giving people haircuts,
because these hands were made
to make people beautiful.
(playful music)
Okay, what was your name again?
- I'm Emily.
- [Grace] Emily.
- [Steph] Hi, I'm Steph.
- Nice to meet you.
- Hi, Steph.
- [Grace] Grace, welcome.
What was your name again?
- Rahul.
- Rahul, what are we
looking for today, Rahul?
- Do you have any major
life events coming up?
- I have a big first date this week.
- Whoa.
- Yeah.
It could be like a make or break.
- I am meeting my girlfriend's
parents in a few days.
- No pressure or anything,
but I'm getting married.
(record scratches)
- Don't say that.
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
- Hold on, like in
general, it's a life goal?
Or it's happening soon?
- It's happening.
- Okay.
- You have a good style
already, great base.
- I would like to look cooler though,
'cause I look a little--
- Impossible!
- I think I look a little nerdy.
- You look nerdy?
No, then we look like giant thumbs.
- What would be an ideal scenario?
- I feel like I'd really
like to channel my like,
Lord of the Rings elf look.
- Oh, okay, you wanna
look like Orlando Bloom?
- This is tough to do
because your hair is so good.
- [Grace] Yeah.
- It's like the opposite
of a blank canvas.
It's like you're telling us to add
accents to the Sistine Chapel.
So, you want us to clean up your edges,
is that what they call it?
- Yes.
- I'm gonna start in the back,
because if he's looking
at the back of your head,
or she's looking at the back
of your head, and it's wrong,
then that means the
dates already been over.
Okay, here we go.
- Oh, my God.
- Ready?
Wait, I'll turn you around,
so that you don't have
to feel the pressure.
Here we go.
- It's gonna be okay, baby.
- Here we go, just a quick trim.
Oh, yeah, this is easy.
We should dampen it, right?
- Dampen the edges.
- Dampen the edges, this is
just water, it's just water.
- Also, I love that, on this morning--
Oh, God, right in my face.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm just gonna throw in some braids.
You're gonna look very like, Coachella,
Westworld.
(Mamrie laughs)
- I'm gonna get in there.
- Okay.
You're gonna do scissors?
- I'm just gonna trim off the very--
- Wait, should you turn around,
so they can see the trimming happen?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Grace] It's okay, hair grows.
We're not giving tattoos.
- Do you guys have a machine?
Honestly, I think I'm doing a great job.
- Yeah, that looks great.
Yeah, whoa, magic.
- [Mamrie] Whoa, fairy dust.
- If you had to describe
him in three words,
what would you say?
- I would say,
nerdy, funny, and annoying.
- Oh, it took a turn.
- Oh, honest, honest.
That's good that you guys get to spend
the rest of your life together
with someone you think is annoying.
Oh, does this have to come off?
- No, I think, oh, God.
(razor buzzes)
- That just got louder for
some reason, here we go.
Very steady and beautiful.
- What's happening back there?
I mean, I think that's looking good.
They always do this, they're like.
- Yeah, oh, oh.
- And you can get in there
with your own hands (laughs).
Have you ever played with color?
One that would really
pop on this is a yellow.
- Okay.
- So, my inspiration for this
is like, the lines on a road.
And how when it's like a dashed line,
it's like, "Come on over."
- Where are you getting married?
Oh, my God, I'm literally
becoming a hair stylist.
- Where are you getting married?
- Where are you getting
married, is it open bar?
- [Mamrie] Is there a theme?
- The theme is movies, we
both make movies together.
So, we're doing like a red carpet theme.
- What kind of movies?
I'm gonna really Jersey
Housewives this up right now.
(can hisses)
- There we go.
- That's yellow.
So, I'm going for very like, 90s Clueless,
meets like, Insane Clown Posse fan.
- Oh, my God, same.
- Oh.
You're like a hipster clown.
I'm just really trying to
tease, get a lot of volume.
You have fantastic, thick
hair, I'm so jealous.
Oh, my God, I have two hairs on my head,
and I tease the hell out of them.
Oh, it's very Sonic the Hedgehog.
Whoa, you're kind of like Sharkboy.
- (laughs) Or like Jimmy Neutron,
if he went through a weird icing phase.
- I think this is--
- Whoa, whoa.
Oh, my God, you look like Kat Von D
had a really bratty teenage daughter.
- This would be if
Sonic retired to Hawaii,
and joined a rockabilly band (laughs).
Look at this cool, just
like, subtle pop of color.
- I'm very into that.
- [Grace] Look it, a little stripe.
Dun, dun, da, da.
- We got cornrows.
- Dun, nuh, duh, na.
Is that the graduation
song or the wedding?
- I think it's the wedding one,
I think it's the wedding.
(Grace laughs)
Thank you for being our first customer.
- She looks beautiful, wow.
Excessive and unnecessary.
(Mamrie laughs)
That's what we call our salon.
- Totally.
(Grace laughs)
- Congratulations, good
luck with your marriage.
Good luck with happily ever after.
I mean, you'll never go wrong now.
- Is it okay?
- I like it.
- Okay!
- Phew.
Thank you so much!
- Thank you, Rahul.
Good luck with the date.
- Good luck with your date.
- You're gonna nail it.
- We're wishing you the best.
It was hard, and also, exciting.
'Cause I really, I mean,
wanted everyone to look their best.
- [Mamrie] You know what I
think our like, strength is?
- [Grace] Yeah.
- [Mamrie] Is getting in their brains,
and really, you know, knowing the scenario
of how they need their
hair, the hair scenario.
- Right, and then, also really upselling
a really shitty end product to someone,
I think, is a strong suit of ours.
- Totally.
- Again, I'm Grace.
- I'm Mamrie, check out "This Might Get",
and thanks so much for watching Buzzfeed.
- Goodbye!
(fun music)